بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا جزيلا
لهذه الفرصه تحت هذا اللقاء
بالنسبه لدعوه الرئيس الامريكي السيد
بايدن
تقوم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه والعراقيه
على ترتيب الموعد
في هذا العام
انا بالتقدير واحد من اهم المواضيع التي
يجب ان تناقش هو موضوع اتفاقيه الاطار
الاستراتيجي اتفاقيه الاطار الاستراتيجي
هي واحده من اتفاقيات التي وقعت مع العراق
وتحتاج
[موسيقى]
الى تفعيل بين البلدين
خصوصا وان هناك رغبه جاده لتطوير
هذه العلاقه
يجب ان لا تقتصر علاقتنا بين العراق
والولايات المتحده على الجانب الامني
رغم اهميته لكن يحتاج ان نفعل
الملفات والمجالات الاخرى
وهي مهمه اليوم العراق بلد
يمتلك موارد
اقتصاديه كبيره
وهو بلد مؤثر في سوق الطاقه
وهناك فرص
كثيره ممكن ان تكون
مجالات لعمل الشركات الامريكيه
في مختلف القطاعات
الاقتصاديه والخدميه
والعمرانيه في العراق
بالنسبه
للدور الامني ما يهمنا هو الوضع الامني
وعلاقته مع التحالف الدولي في العراق
اليوم العراق
لا يحتاج الى قوات قتاليه
سواء كانت من الولايات المتحده او من باقي
دول التحالف الدولي اليوم القوات الامنيه
العراقيه وصلت الى مرحله متقدمه من
الجاهزيه والامكانيه والمقدر على المحافظه
على استقرار الامن وتعقب خلايا داعش التي
تمثل مجاميع تطارد في الصحاره والجبال
والكهوف
وليس لها اي
مكان ولا تهدد كيان الدوله
بالتاكيد نحن نرفض اي اعتداء على الحدود
العراقيه سواء كان من الجانب التركي او
الايراني
السياده العراقيه
وامن الاراضي العراقيه لا تخضع
لاي مجامله
هذا من جانب من جانب اخر ايضا العراق
ملتزم وفق ما نص عليه الدستور
بعدم السماح لاي مجاميع مسلحه ان تستغل
وجودها على الاراضي العراقيه
للاعتداء على الدول الجوار لذلك عملت
الحكومه طيله الفتره الماضيه مع الدول
الجاره تركيا وايران على تشكيل لجان امنيه
هذا ما حصل مع ايران وحددنا مجموعه من
النقاط والالتزامات المهمه والتي نفذت
مؤخرا
بشهاده الجانبين هذا الامر سوف يضيف
استقرار على الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه
مع الجاره التركيه
للاسف كان الحادث الاخير في السليمانيه
ادى الى استشهاد ثلاثه من منتسبي الاجهزه
الامنيه في اقليم كردستان في محافظه
سليمان نحن نجري مباحثات
حاليا مع الاتراك اليوم هناك لقاء للسيد
وزير الخارجيه العراقي مع النظير التركي
ايضا الموقف الرسمي للدوله العراقيه كان
واضح في رفض هذه الاعتداءات ومعالجه اي
ملاحظات امنيه من خلال اللجان المشتركه
ومن خلال الحوار
العلاقه مع ايران ايران دوله جاره
وهناك مشتركات كثيره
على المستوى الديني
والاجتماعي
والثقافي ايران كانت دوله داعمه للعمليه
السياسيه ودعم لجهود العراق في مكافحه
الارهاب وخصوصا في الحرب ضد داعش
بالتاكيد النظره العراقيه لهذه العلاقه
قائمه على مبدا المصالح المشتركه كما هو
الحال في نظرتنا للعلاقه مع باقي الدول
سواء كان دول الجوار او دول العالم
المصالح المشتركه عدم التدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه هي المبادئ التي
تستند عليها علاقتنا مع الجاره ايران
بالتاكيد هناك فرص
كثيره
تستثمر بالشكل الصحيح
لمنفعه البلدين
جارين ونحن نعمل على ذلك
يهمنا جدا ايضا ان يكون هناك وجهات نظر
متقاربه لايران مع اشقائنا العرب بالشكل
الذي يساهم في تعزيز الاستقرار في هذه
المنطقه الحساسه من العالم
نحن نتحدث دائما مع الاصدقاء عن مضامين
علاقتنا مع الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران
هذا الحديث الذي ذكرته في البدايه
كذلك نؤكد دائما
باننا نمتلك قرارنا الوطني الذي يستند الى
المصلحه الوطنيه
للعراق ولا ننساه لرغبات الاخرين ونتحدث
بصراحه مع الجميع في حال وجود اي خروقات
او تدخل سياده البلد انا نحن ننظر الى
الموقف الرسمي
للقياده الايرانيه هذا الموقف واضح امامنا
هو موقف الداعم للدوله العراقيه للاستقرار
في العراق
لوجود عراق قوي
بالتاكيد هذه كلها ثوابت من خلال علاقاتنا
التي امتدت خصوصا في هذه الفتره بعد
التغيير وهذا ما نبني عليه اي تحرك خارج
هذا الاطار فهو مرفوض ويواجه باجراءات
حازمه من قبل الحكومه العراقيه بالشكل
الذي يمنع المساس بالسياده او العبث
باستقرار وامن العراق